now to a disturbing story about a woman
who died behind bars in Washington State
Damaris Rodriguez was a mother of five
much of her ordeal was caught on video
and we want to warn you it is difficult
to watch he or she is late in 2017 on
one of her last days alive in
surveillance footage first broadcast by
our Seattle affiliate Cairo she wound up
naked hallucinating and in apparent
distress after four days of alleged
neglect Niki Fatih spoke to Rodriguez's
son Nicky why was she arrested good
morning around well that is the big
question according to the family's
lawsuit Rodriguez was suffering from a
quote mental health episode when her
husband called 9-1-1 that's when police
arrived and arrested her for fourth
degree assault
Damaris Rodriguez's husband won in
medical help when he placed this 9-1-1
call in late 2017 she's having a
psychiatric problem and isn't behaving
normally she's being violent and has
already hit me twice and I need a medic
really cool instead police arrived first
and carried Rodriguez into the
Washington state jail known as score
Jose Marte is the mother of fives oldest
son I was upset and I was angry my
mother never been arrested jail
surveillance video shows his mother at
one point undressing at time she's seen
crawling appearing to vomit and banging
on the door after about four days she is
found dead in her cell as far as you
know had your mom been diagnosed with a
mental disorder yes she has Rodriguez
his family says she had previously been
diagnosed and treated for bipolar
disorder why is your family filed a
lawsuit to bring justice to what has
happened and so people can know about
these type of situations that are
happening in these jail system I feel
like all of those could have been
prevented the family's lawsuit claims
Rodriguez eventually died from an easily
diagnoseable and treatable metabolic
condition called ketoacidosis I'd
describe it as a window into hell I mean
it's a terrible video family attorney
Nate Bingham says score staff was unable
to
yuuna Kate with Rodriguez when somebody
is so mentally ill that they can't
communicate then that's a sign of a
really big problem in a statement to CBS
News the facility extended its
condolences to all involved saying since
this incident our employees have
received comprehensive training in
crisis intervention it says according to
the police department no malicious
criminal act contributed to her death as
a general rule the courts have
determined an inmate must be charged
with a crime or released within 72 hours
of arrest Rodriguez was incarcerated for
103 hours before her death and never was
formally charged since the incident
according to scores website two other
people have died at the jail and
according to their website the death and
those two cases the cause is unknown
Nikki so many questions just think about
that for a second the husband calls for
help
mental health for his for help for his
wife and he ends up with a dead wife and
she's in jail and not charged longer
than she should have been it makes no
sense
be the first ones to tell you that
they're not mental health providers but
mental health providers should have been
called in yes we need a lot of work
about mental health yes so many
questions or thank you Nikki